[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi est 5e
juin 14 heures de concert et 4000
participants la deuxième édition du
festival électro hors série avait lieu
au vélodrome et nous y avons assisté le
18e cycliques c'est ce vendredi quatre
établissements vont s'affronter le
collège de manial magny les hameaux
remet son titre en jeu et nous les avons
rencontrés et le 14 juin prochain le
mois molière verra se produire sur scène
des comédiens de sixième il participe au
projet trier ses jouets ou sommes allés
à la rencontre d'une de ces classes hors
série épisodes de après la gare
saint-lazare c'était le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui accueillait la nuit de l'électro un
marathon de 14 heures de musique assurée
par des artistes des scènes house et
techno internationale nicolas landry
s'est glissée dans l'air centrale
regarder les vélos ont été rangés
remplacé par les platines de dimanche à
lundi le vélodrome nationale a vécu 14
heures de concert cinq artistes et
groupes se sont succédé
[Musique]
trois heures de 7 pour un état dj
membres du blockhaus un collectif
promouvant la technique ça sort un peu
les gens est à voir dans les clubs déjà
et puis je trouve que
ça va dans la logique de
la démocratisation de
de la techno d'être dans des lieux aussi
imposant emblématique pour paris
importante dans l'air centrale un public
venu de toute la france montigny le
bretonneux bien sûr mais aussi coup dans
caen lyon paris ou encore marseille déjà
pour m'éclater avec mes potes taper un
peu du pied et s'amuser comme on peut
pour faire la fête
on a entendu y avait une soirée poteau
façon il y avait des bons cette heure on
est venu tout de suite on adore la
techno tous du coup on est venu pour
vraiment s'éclater toute la soirée je
voulais faire la route série
qui est à dire saint lazare j'ai
malheureusement pas pu la terre et j'ai
eu des retours de monstrueux qui était
officines et là j'ai vu là hors série je
me suis dit qu'il fallait absolument que
ça passe succès donc pour ce deuxième
rendez vous hors série après la gare
saint lazare en septembre dernier près
de 4000 personnes ont dansé jusqu'au
petit matin
quatre collèges pour un vainqueur le 9
juin c'est le 18ème siècle imite le
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale sur scène les
collèges de la géo d'elancourt gustave
courbet de trappes alexandre dumas de
maurepas et l'établissement tony tenant
du titre le collège albert einstein de
magny les hameaux
michael almy doro a assisté à l'une des
répétitions des manic war regarder il
s'agit du collège albert einstein home a
dit le vainqueur
dix trophées 2016
il est vrai que le trophée de match
d'improvisation intercollèges restent
chez eux
leymen quoi du collège albert einstein
revoient leurs gammes
l'idée aujourd'hui et sur le court
prochain c'est tenter des choses
d'accord tenter des mises en scène
prenez des risques amusez vous ok on se
précisent sur certains certains sujets
comme la on a vu les balances donc c'est
le fait que yanakis tête pendant qu'elle
a d'autres qui sont qui sont par terre
et inversement
en fait on revoit un peu de ce qu'on a
travaillé pendant l'année mais en ayant
plus de liberté deux minutes c'est parti
je pense que c'est la diversité des jeux
parce qu'on a un jeu assez différent en
fait en enfin des actes des comédiens
enfin des tic au mieux à 16 10 mai des
élèves de l'équipe donc je pense que
c'est ça qui fait la force
ils ont entre 11 et 14 ans ils partent
comme favoris à quelques jours du
concours ces collégiens et sont d'une
certaine pression
leur coach en toile donne ses derniers
conseils il faut une histoire plus
construite que sa plus importante que ça
des gens on essaie de les détendre parce
que malgré tout c'est des événements qui
sont hyper impressionnant pour eux ils
sont dans des grandes salles et tous
leurs copains qui viennent les voir
donc on essaie de les rassurer en
en les enrichissant
mais c'est en blindant on ne cerne
l'inde est ce qu'ils savent déjà faire
plus que deux marches à gravir pour
inscrire à nouveau leur nom sur le
trophée
ils n'ont qu'une idée en tête d'autres
collégiens seront aussi sur scène des
sixièmes de versailles grand parc honte
écrit et mis en scène de spectacles
autour d'une thématique les déchets le
projet prix j'ai trié ces jouets est
initié par la communauté d'agglomération
le metteur en scène éric bouvron la
compagnie barefoot et le mois molière
nous avons rencontré les apprentis
comédiens du collège raymond poincaré à
versailles une fable de la fontaine des
tournées
c'est le fil conducteur de leur
spectacle ces élèves de 6e du collège
raymond poincaré participe à trier ses
jouets un projet pédagogique c'est de
faire réfléchir et faire s'exprimer les
enfants à propos du recyclage de
l'environnement général mais là plus axé
sur le recyclage et les déchets et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des déchets à
travers une approche ludique et
artistique où ils vont pouvoir
s'exprimer en créant en écrivant
composants
imaginons des danses et des textes tout
ce qu'ils veulent accompagnés de leur
professeur de français d'un intervenant
ils créent leur histoire de a à z chacun
ramener un peu de sa paume et et bas à
la fronde a tout mélangé et ça fait
quelque chose d'assez d'assez bien avec
le prof etc
même si le projet de base c'est quand
même dont de s'amuser et tout ça c'est
quand même un vrai problème pour
l'humanité
le problème de la pollution du gâchis
mais tout ça leur spectacle c'est le
résultat de six séances d'une heure et
demie de travail étalées sur deux mois
une représentation unique est prévue
durant le mois molière
[Musique]
pour le coup de coeur cinéma de cette
semaine on part à saint cyr l'école et
on écoute marie-lune pour coup de coeur
du cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette semaine
c'est le festival les yeux pleins
d'étoilés puisque c'est notre sixième
édition est une édition placée sous le
signe de la famille donc puisque c'est
un événement familial y en a pour tous
les goûts tous les âges
alors ça commence avec un événement
inédit dimanche une avant-première du
grand méchant renard le film de benjamin
renner qui avait réalisé 1 est et
célestine en partenariat avec
l'association contrechamp est ce que tu
viens quand résumé michel je m'en occupe
si tu veux ça ne me dérange pas du tout
non mais ça va
samedi 17 juin une journée autour des
familles fantastique avec notamment
signer continue pour les plus petits à
partir de 2 ans à 10 heures avec la
conteuse charlotte gillot et puis pour
terminer ponyo sur la falaise le
dimanche 18 à 16 heures avec un ciné
goûter projection départementale voilà
vous pouvez retrouver le programme de
notre festival sur le site de la ville
de saint cyr l'école et à bientôt
j'espère ponyo sur la falaise sera aussi
à découvrir au ciné cette d'elancourt ce
dimanche 11 juin on regarde un extrait
[Musique]
oh
et
le festival du court-métrage des
clayes-sous-bois sixième édition ça se
passait le week-end dernier une
vingtaine de films étaient en
compétition
sept prix ont été remis à l'issue d'une
après midi de projection retour sur
l'événement avec des images de nicolas
d'embûches seulement 40 minutes de
délibération pour le jury 18 courts
métrages participer au 6e festival des
clayes-sous-bois le premier critère
c'est l'émotion c'est à dire quels sont
les films qui nous ont vraiment touchés
et qu'ils nous ont apporté quelque chose
de neuf
quelque chose d'original qu'on n'avait
pas déjà vu ou qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir d'habitude c'est très tranché la
sélection il ya à la fois des comédies
qui sont parfois très réussie et très
drôle et des films très très sombre et
c'est c'était assez étonnant de voir
qu'on passait de là à l'autre
sept trophées ont été remis le plus
prestigieux celui du jury a été décerné
à y réaliser par nicolas ozenne
l'histoire de pauline 17 ans qui
multiplie les aventures d'un soir après
une déception amoureuse
tu sais pas ce que c'est que mais en
fait divers toi fais toi du bien sinon
c'est un petit tour chez piper surpris
hyper content évidemment
je sais que tout le monde ici pas mais
je m'y attendais pas franchement je suis
vraiment très très content les mots du
jury m'ont extrêmement touché le fait
qu'à chaque fois on rencontre des gens
des jeunes femmes qui se disent qu'il se
retrouve dans le personnage principal ça
nous touche énormément avec la
scénariste on voulait faire un film qui
soit
qu'ils soient qui vivent dans le sens où
on l'aimé ou on le déteste quoi mais que
en tout cas qu'il provoque une réaction
le prix du public a été remis à daniel
brunet nicolas d'oust pour speed dating
une comédie romantique où un homme à 7
minutes pour séduire une femme assis sur
une bombe mais pour toi je suis là pour
satisfaire toutes vos questions
merde vous savez ce que ça veut dire
ce gars là n'a jamais dragué de sa vie
c'est une fois pour repêché un cadavre
[Musique]
un autre rendez vous dans les salles
obscures un ciné débat est proposé par
l'équipe des cinq fasciné des étudiantes
en master de l'ue vs qu va vis et
deviens sera projeté et à l'issue le
réalisateur débattra avec le public
regardez
l' orchestre symphonique de la batterie
s'associe à celui d'alphonse daudet pour
un concert le 8 juin et proposeront des
oeuvres de ravel bizet et brahms et les
présentations de saison continue pour la
ferme de bel ébat c'est le 13 juin avec
un bal le groupe alligators et les
artistes de la saison vous donneront un
aperçu
la réservation est conseillée voilà le 7
une culture est maintenant terminée je
vous remercie de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]